in the spirit of the holidays I'm going
to surprise someone who I'm extremely
grateful for that works on the Kelly
Clarkson show I'm going to write them a
letter deliver it to them and read it
out loud and the best part is that they
have no idea this is happening
I'm calling this ambush
[Music]
so who I'm picking today is so
monumentally pivotal for the show to
happen and work this is Lisa the
teleprompter goddess I literally like
whether it's a song that I literally you
think you know you don't like I have her
running those lyrics everywhere for me
just in case I don't mess people's
lyrics up yet I still happen to do it
sometimes so that's the genius part of
that but Lisa is we make so many changes
on the fly on this show and we have to
move things around and things just
happen all the time so she's constantly
having to change things in the
teleprompter but also having to have it
on time and in sync with me actually
being live in at the moment and it's an
incredibly difficult job and I would not
want it but she excels at it she's
amazing and it actually happens to be
Lisa's birthday today which is genius I
actually chose her without knowing that
and so I love that it's her birthday as
well she's amazing
[Music]
I don't know how she's gonna react she's
but she seems a bit shy so I hope we
embarrass her slightly cuz I find that
fun
alright so Lisa works in the control
room obviously so we're gonna go to the
control we're gonna find her right now
and I'm gonna read this letter aloud to
her here we go guys got some cupcakes me
for birthday and have the letter
hopefully we embarrass her a tiny bit oh
hi
okay so first of all happy birthday to
you happy birthday to you happy birthday
dear Lisa other cupcakes are awesome
happy birthday to you here's the best
part I actually didn't know it was your
birthday when I picked you for this for
this day but it no literally it was
coincident it ended up hat
anyway so we have a new segment on
digital that we call ambush thank you
and obviously it was like you and Jason
Halbert my first two that I did cuz like
you're my lifeline so I wrote you a
letter Lisa thank you so much for being
the greatest teleprompter goddess in all
of the universe literally I couldn't do
this job without you you know that's
true thank you for just being playing
badass and it's your birthday so
perfectly like we didn't know who's
getting in on this day so it was awesome
you really are the best at what you do
the first time is Billboard Awards right
without wait for it when does the first
time
oh that's what oh my god that was the
first time yes and we were all sitting
in there yes I was like I remember him
being in a room and I was like oh god
can we hire her for everything because
nobody generally I'm telling you it's a
talent like nobody ever does a
teleprompter like that well I know it
sounds silly but it's not to us anyway
oh that's sad that's a rare thing I
always paint getting these compliments
people are like oh you're you're so nice
you knew my name and I'm like should
people not know your name like what oh
my gosh well that was a low bar that
somebody said so I surpassed that low
bar I promise to make it even better
sad sucks of course I know your name
what a horrible I always get those
compliments my whole career people will
be like oh you're so nice you like said
hi and I'm like did what
that's not or like oh you're nice and
I'm like what you bake cookies wait can
I have one I love it I'm taking your
cookies and they do not need sugar
that's delicious
it is it's the salt and sweet it's like
a munchies dream snack you want me a
present on your Amber's thank you dude
you really are you rocket what you do I
say it all the time to everybody around
us
you really are incredible we do
especially being on the fly
all right girl you go ahead and make
cookies anytime you want I'm just so
amazed and shocked she is such a
beautiful hearted person and I'm just
I'm just overwhelmed Thank You Kelly
you're amazing and I love you
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this